vous présentons aujourd'hui une
proposition de la vision à protéger les
logements contre l'occupation illicite
nous le voyons encore très souvent dans
l'actualité des petits propriétaires
sont victimes d'occupation illicites à
Saint-Ouen à Carcassonne à Marseille
encore à Toulouse les cas de squat et de
logement
occupés sans loyer rendent la vie des
petits propriétaires impossible je
repense à Maryse et Pierre Garcia couple
de ses pièges générales à Marseille qui
ont été obligés de vivre pendant deux
ans dans un camping-car en raison des
impayés de leur locataires et il y a des
exemples assez régulièrement ces
situations elles sont insupportables et
face à ces actes illicites nous avons
déjà agi l'article 38 de la loi DALO a
été modifiée en 2020 avec la loi ASAP
dont j'étais le rapporteur en mettant en
place une procédure Express d'expulsion
en 72 heures y compris quand il ne
s'agit pas d'une résidence principale
c'est via la saisie directe du préfet et
cela faisait depuis 2007 que la
procédure n'avait pas été améliorée
c'est notre majorité qui l'a fait les
résultats sont là en 2021 on a eu 170
victimes de squatteurs qui ont pu
récupérer leur logement en quelques
jours qui serait probablement encore
dans les méandres de l'administration si
nous n'allions pas modifié la loi nous
avons la conviction qu'il faut aller
plus loin sur les squats notre
proposition elle va permettre de tripler
les sanctions pénales qui pèsent sur les
squatteurs en les passant à 3 ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amende
elle va permettre aussi de clarifier la
procédure d'expulsion avec notamment le
fait qu'un logement vide de meubles
pourra bien bénéficier de l'action
express du préfet c'est par exemple pour
sécuriser les déménagements quand vous
vous retrouvez avec un logement qui est
vide de meubles sur les impayés
notre proposition elle vise à mieux
accompagner les bailleurs dans les
procédures administratives et
judiciaires on va proposer de créer un
délit d'occupation sans droit ni titre
en violation d'une décision de justice
du logement d'autrui elle permettra aux
propriétaires du logement d'attaquer en
justice en occupant sans droit ni titre
quand celui-ci se maintient en dépit
d'une décision de justice on propose
également de sécuriser la clause de
résiliation dans les contrats locatifs
d'une part en rendant obligatoire cette
clause de résiliation et puis en
sécurisant son exécution et en revenant
sur la capacité du juge en prendre
l'exécution et enfin nous proposons deux
réductions de délai dans la procédure
qui permettront de ramasser la procédure
et d'aller plus vite voilà le contenu de
cette proposition de loi qui permettra à
nous l'espérons à des milliers de
propriétaires modestes de surmonter
l'épreuve que peut constituer
l'occupation illicite de l'horlogements
pendant parfois des années et des années